depuis janvier 2010 est en ville comme
ici à bourges pissenlit et plantains
envahissent les trottoirs dans les
petites communes depuis l'interdiction
de l'utilisation des pesticides les élus
réagissent
la communauté de communes du haut berry
a signé une charte avec nature 18
on sait que l'on pourra pas garder un
aspect identique à ce que c'était avec
les pesticides c'est des techniques
différentes c'est une planification
différentes d aménagement différent
nous notre travail c'est de faire en
sorte que les pissenlits choc de moins
en moins de gens parce qu'au final un
pissenlit c'est toujours une fleur qui
va être pollinisées par des insectes qui
va qui participe quand même un
écosystème y compris en ville y compris
dans les villages la nature c'est
important fleurs aux mauvaises herbes
c'est le dilemme des employés municipaux
à saint palais on utilise un système
mécanique pour enlever les mauvaises
herbes
certains accotements ont droit à un
autre traitement
avant ils ont les herbes et aux produits
je reste propre savez une bordure de
route propre une bande quoi propre
disant que c'était un trottoir piétons
aménagé en grave et qu'on laisse
maintenant basse en herbe est
naturellement une maintenant on dit que
c'est propre
un peu plus loin au cimetière le sable a
été remplacé entre les tombes il fallait
trouver une solution également pour
éviter de mettre des pesticides donc sur
le terrain et ce qui me semblait le plus
opportun c'était de semer du gazon mais
du gazon qui lève
assez rapidement mais qui après pousse
très tout doucement la prochaine étape
de cette loi c'est pour janvier 2019
hélas les particuliers eux aussi ne
pourront plus utiliser les pesticides et
donc ils devront avoir une démarche plus
environnementale pour leurs allées et
leurs jardins